welcome to the heavy spoiler show
i'm your host paul aka the guy who spent
his entire life
looking for the infinity stones how do
you have these
oh we actually got a lot of those yeah
some of the guys use them as paper
weights
what now loki episode one has a lot
going on with it
and after our big easter egg breakdown
yesterday there's been a couple more
details i found that i think are worth
going over
this includes what could be a peggy
carter sighting how the show sets up
doctor strange 2
and a lot more now if you haven't had a
chance to check out the episode yet then
i highly suggest you erase this video
from your timeline
and come back when you have make sure
you drop a thumbs up if you like the
theories
and don't forget to subscribe for a
variety of videos for people who have
too much time on their hands
without the way thank you for clicking
this now let's get into the easter egg
breakdown
okay so after loki steals mobius and
mobius's time twister
he warps back to the lobby of the tva in
the background we see someone being
brought in
and the internet has been going
absolutely wild with speculation
over whether this is peggy carter or not
the first person who sent me this was
wallow cassette on twitter
so shout outs them but i'm actually
erasing them from the timeline to claim
that i found it
because i'm an absolute egomaniac
now i've been like the tva and working
overtime
watching this clip almost on a loop all
day to see if it's her or not
i'd recognize haley atwell anywhere and
though this clip is too blurry to see i
do think that it is a different actress
however we do know from the show that
there are different versions of loki
walking around
so potentially this could also be an
alternate version of peggy carter
her dress and hair are quite similar
things that we've seen peggy wearing
before
and her clothes look like they come from
the 40s now why the tva might be after
her
is because the russo brothers confirmed
that at the end of end game
steve traveled back in time to have a
life with her and this was
somewhat a dance with the devil it
created an alternate timeline
in which steve was well aware of the
events of the mcu
and the butterfly effect of this action
would have drastically altered peggy's
life
peggy was of course a founding member of
shield and thus her having even a minor
change could have had disastrous
consequences for reality
the tva as a whole clearly worshipped
the idea of one timeline
and in the comics their entire existence
was built around stopping alternate
branches that had been sprung up
this would mean that an alternate
version of peggy who would go on to have
steve's children
and live a life with him would be
considered a dangerous offshoot
and thus she is someone that would be a
target for them
now steve rogers has the super soldier
serum within him and he's one of the
best hand-to-hand fighters in the mcu
that we've met so far
i really think that the tva would have
difficulty taking him in
and thus they might turn to peggy
instead as she'd be a lot easier
we know from various reports that chris
evans is supposed to be coming back to
reprise his role as captain america
and i would absolutely love it in a film
if we picked up right after that dance
with his life in the 50s
only to have it all taken away yes i'm a
sick sick
bastard now bear in mind we don't really
see any more of cap's life between the
dance and him meeting sam at the bench
so things may not have been as happy as
they seem
if this is peggy i'd absolutely love it
if she was taken prisoner
and the show culminated with loki
bringing down the tva which allowed her
to return to her life with steve
for whatever reason their timeline seems
to remain untouched so
someone or something has clearly stopped
the tva from destroying it
now shout outs to my buddy over at
superhero nexus for recently theorizing
that this could also be the captain
britain version of peggy from what if
in that series we're going to be
exploring events from the mcu
with the possibility that certain things
happen differently
we know that there will be an episode
focused heavily around peggy
in which he ends up taking the super
soldier serum instead of steve
potentially this could lead to the tva
stepping in and
taking her from the reality at the end
of it so that it doesn't create a branch
timeline
i can't really see that being how the
cartoon series ends but you know we're
just theorizing here
so shut the hell up now in the lobby of
the tva
we also see a scroll in a tracksuit who
could potentially be pulled from a what
if episode
i think it would be great if throughout
this series we encounter several
different people in the tva hq
that all come from the show and this
scroll itself might even be from the
hawkeye series
it has been reported that the tracksuit
mafia will be showing up in the first
season
and with this skrull wearing one it is
possible that he may have been a member
those are just theories for now but i
don't think it's a secret to say that
the multiverse is coming down the line
with several actors and characters
returning for spider-man no way home
and also the fact that doctor strange 2
has the subtitle in the multiverse of
madness attached to it
that lets us know that everything it's
gonna go to hell
yay now speaking of hell you know who
rules over hell
interestingly there was actually a big
hint towards this in the ms minutes
infomercial
that talked about how the tva operate
she actually used the words
madness and the phrase in the multiverse
to perhaps hint towards the upcoming
film
which this will no doubt have serious
ramifications on
when discussing face for the mcu kevin
feige stated that one division
loki no way home and in the multiverse
of madness we'll all be connected
and this could be the offshoot that
breaks the multiverse in those films
it's all connected now with what if
peggy carter potentially being there and
all the issues that are coming down the
line i really think that the show could
either end one of two ways
we may get the tva simply returning loki
to where he was
after a couple of life lessons and then
instead of picking up the tesseract
he just lets it go this would allow the
timeline to continue as normal
but it would also enable him to plan for
his death in infinity war
and as we all know he's used doubles
before to fake it
this prior knowledge wouldn't really
alter the timeline but it would allow
for him to still come back in the future
now the other option which i think is a
lot more fun is that he
and the other lucky variants help to
break the multiverse
this will end the show on a big
cliffhanger of what could be
and also get us hyped for what's around
the corner
personally that's the way i'd love to
see it go and the warnings of a
multiversal wall
they were clearly put in place to hint
towards what happens when everything
goes haywire
if you're a fan of marvel comics you
will be aware that secret wars pretty
much dealt with a range of realities
fighting for dominance
and the arc contains several versions of
characters i know a lot of my followers
are dc fans though
so just think crisis on infinite earths
and you get the idea
now other easter eggs i've noticed since
re-watching the episode of that the
tesseract is much more dimmer in the tva
headquarters than it was in the main
timeline
when we first see it at the start of the
episode it's glowing bright blue
but this is slowly diminished over time
and eventually it just looks like a
regular cube that you'd get at a gift
shop
it originally emanates a noise that
sounds like a high-pitched choir
but when loki discovers that there's
several versions of the infinity stones
kept in a draw
this dies down showing its lack of power
now there's been lots of questions over
how they managed to get so many of them
and shout outs ryanairy from screen
crush for saying that these all likely
come from timelines that have since been
erased
in avengers endgame we learned that
removing one could have had disastrous
effects
but the tva don't seem like the
sentimental type
and they have no problem completely
eliminating timelines from existence
should they not see them fit to continue
potentially in these other realities
someone could have picked up an infinity
stone and they may have been brought in
with it on their body
loki at the start of the episode is
taken in carrying the space stone
so it makes sense that other ones could
have came to the tva through the exact
same circumstances
anyway that's pretty much most of the
new things that i spotted
but i will be back over the weekend with
a video breaking down not only the tva
but also the timekeepers and mobius and
mobius
obviously i'd love to hear your thoughts
on these theories in the comments below
remember this probably isn't peggy but
you've watched to the end of the video
now and it's always fun to speculate
these kinds of things between the weekly
releases
now as a thank you for interacting with
the video you'll be entered into a prize
through on the 30th of june
in which we're giving away three copies
of the phase 3 mcu box set
all you have to do to be with a chance
of winning is like the video
make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the episode
the winners of last month's competition
are on screen right now so that's you
then message me on twitter at
heavyspoilers
if you want something else to watch then
make sure you check out our full
breakdown of the episode which will be
linked on screen right now
we pointed out pretty much all the
easter eggs had a lot of fun reviewing
it
and it's definitely worth checking out
if you're bored and just want something
else to watch
without the way thank you for sticking
through the video i've been paul i'll
see you next time
take care peace